[Music]
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
on the show today is Dr Joe dispenza who
really needs no introduction he is the
most amazing human at getting people to
accept the idea of getting beyond their
body he really helps people with that
transition he has Retreats he has books
um he's on lots of podcasts and does
lots of interviews so that you can help
understand his work but let me tell you
from someone who's been to Retreats of
his and his week-long he really helps
you understand the power of meditation
and the power of creating and that you
are a Creator and you're creating your
reality every day by what you put your
point of attention on we go unconscious
when we start to use the mind and when
we're conscious when we're allowing for
the flow of things to happen and getting
out of that thinking mind which only
regurgitates and puts you in the same
same patterns that you've already been
in over and over and over again probably
since you were a kid super deep dive
great conversation about creating in 5D
the power of meditation knowing versus
believing and where the magic sauces and
manifesting and creating the reality
that you want and then essentially his
mission and what he hopes to accomplish
so enjoy the show please hit subscribe
hit the bell for notifications when a
new episode comes out I just truly enjoy
doing this show let me hear your
thoughts in the comments
and have a great day
I remember you talking about that like
magic is supposed to be normal it's a
side effect it's really the side effect
I mean I expect that when I meditate I
don't do it for any other reason that
really to shorten the distance between
the thought of what I want and the
experience of having it that's the
that's the grace that's the fun what's
the magic sauce yes with the magic sauce
is you and me I mean that's it it's just
us that we have all the resources we
just got to do it that's it
I felt like the magic sauce from a
practical standpoint was
embodying the feeling having
accomplished it like it's one thing to
know why you want it and it's another
thing to for those like if so catch up
people for a second since we're on this
topic
um you did a manifestation technique
where we thought about what we wanted
and it could be anything right it could
be a shopping trip it could be a car it
could be a whatever any anything that
you want to manifest and then sort of
represent that with a letter and then on
you know one side of the letter you
write down three four five reasons why
and then on the other side you write
down three or four five reasons or
elevated emotions having accomplished it
and so then we went into the meditation
and we did it and anyway two hours later
it happened and somebody goes oh there's
a trip to Egypt in February if you want
to go and so boom here we are now so
that to me feels like what the magic
sauce is is that right or
well um let's talk about it I think that
we're we've been hypnotized and
conditioned into believing that you know
we have to do something in order to have
an experience in three-dimensional
reality and this is the plane of
demonstration so when we have the
experience the end product of an
experience is an emotion right so that's
the payoff when you when you have your
abundance when you have your new
relationship when you have your new
career you you you live in separation
from the emotion until the experience
occurs and then when the experience
occurs it takes away the lack or
separation of not having it nothing
wrong with that that's the rules of
three-dimensional reality and you can
get really good at it you know you could
go to school you can make the right
choices you can learn from your mistakes
you can be
trained to get better at it and you can
develop skills and and you can you know
you can accumulate resources and it can
get easier for you but in the quantum
if you're creating from the field
instead of from matter which is a broad
conversation you have to feel it in
order to experience it
and so that's uh that's kind of a
reversal because most people say well
I'm not going to feel gratitude until my
healing actually happens well it turns
out that you got to feel gratitude in
order for the healing to happen and our
data shows that over and over again so
your body is uh so objective
that when you feel the emotion before
the experience it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone the body's actually
believing it's living a new environment
a new uh uh condition so it turns out it
requires if you're looking at a secret
sauce we've kind of whittled it down to
a formula
and it requires a clear intention
and that is a vision of what you want to
have happen and that is selecting a new
possibility an unknown that you would
like to experience okay so what does
that require that requires your brain
being really coherent
so if we've isolated the process of
being able to make your brain work
better and I I talk to the brain
scientists a few times and I said tell
me what percentage of people that
immerse themselves in an event for seven
days what percentage of those people do
their do their brains get better these
they said 100 100 so we know that you
can make your brain work better if you
learn that formula
okay so now we have a clear intention
but that's only one element there is
another element that is the handmaiden
to that and that is an elevated emotion
now elevated emotion I'm talking about
you can so many people feel with every
single body part except their heart I
mean that's just kind of a weird thing
that we do as human beings well you
protect that you know it's you're being
vulnerable in the jungle is means you're
you're more likely to be taken advantage
of you know and you get bruised or
injured in your life
uh you kind of learn from that and you
gotta you get you you protect it right
so in the creative process the heart is
the creative Center we have compelling
data to show that once you open that
heart of yours and it starts beating in
a rhythm and a coherence it actually
informs the brain
uh it's safe to create it actually tells
the brain to get creative and brain
waves change and so
when you combine that coherent heart and
elevated emotion and you start feeling
the emotions before the experience the
heart actually produces an external
magnetic field well now you got a Wi-Fi
signal and that field could actually
resonate with a coherent brain the
intent and the thought is the electrical
charge that sends the signal out it's
the directive and the elevated emotion
that that feeling is a magnetic charge
and we've got enough information to show
that the heart's the magnet so you're
going to draw the experience to you with
your heart so when there's a kind of
match in frequency between some
potential in the quantum field and what
you would like to experience and you
keep tuning in to that potential and
you're you're actually creating from the
field instead of from matter the rules
change yeah now you don't have to go
anywhere to get what you want somehow
The Experience finds you and it comes in
unexpected and surprising ways to prove
to you that you're actually a Creator in
your life and so true when that occurs
then it's no longer like I have to
meditate it's actually like I'm not
going to stop doing this because I don't
want the magic to end and so that's what
I'm really super proud about in our
community we're doers you know we we do
the work you know not because we have to
or to please God or do the right thing
or not feel guilty or we do it because
we don't want the magic to end in all
those synchronicities all those
coincidences all those opportunities
that start appearing in our life to
prove to us what I did inside of me
is somehow producing some effect outside
of me and if I can correlate what I did
inside with me with those
synchronicities those opportunities that
are happening outside of me I'm going to
pay attention to what I'm doing and do
it again in my belief
in what's possible actually broadens and
oh gosh I've been studying people in the
last uh six months or so because I might
my belief
about what's possible has actually
changed in witnessing so many people's
Transformations I never thought I would
see multiple uh multiple sclerosis or
muscular dystrophy or amytrophic lateral
sclerosis or blindness or
paralysis uh change in in seven days I
mean this is kind of crazy stuff that
we're witnessing and I I listen to the
testimonials of these people and I talk
to them
and what they change
is their doubt in what's possible and
and we were kind of talking about this
before we started it's so relevant for
all of us because some people think they
do the meditation if I do this
meditation I'll heal and when I listened
really closely to those people and some
of them did their meditations two and
three times a day why because no chemo
no drug no surgery no diet no exercise
was actually changing their health at
all and nothing
changes in our life until we change yeah
so they were doing their meditation two
and three times a day not because they
thought if I meditate more and try
harder it's going to work they defaulted
back to the doubt that it was possible
now
when you're when you respond and react
to someone or something in your life and
you get back into the familiar feeling
of yourself you're going to believe in
your past more than you're going to
believe in your future so they did the
meditation to change their state they
got that clear intention back again they
felt their elevated emotion when they
felt the elevated emotion they actually
believed in their future again because
they could feel they could feel
connected to it so they were doing their
meditations two and three times a day
not to do it more so they could heal but
they defaulted back to their doubt and
they had to go back and change their
belief in so many of them now after
their moment um God we have so much so
many great testimonials and I listen
really closely they say now I have no
doubt like no doubt there was a guy in
London that came to our event in August
with muscular dystrophy a really rare
form of Baker's or slim guards muscular
dystrophy it's Progressive that you look
at it on the internet anywhere it'll say
there is no cure for it he came in a
wheelchair
he walked out of that event he walked he
was walking he they just sent me a video
of him this week walking down the street
in India just strolling down the street
like like you you I don't know if people
really understand like the magnitude of
that that is going so against convention
it's such an unusual thing to witness I
watched that video 50 times in the
beginning over and over again because I
just had to say wow this is unbelievable
I gotta really remember
what's possible as human beings and it
is really changing our belief uh from a
state of Doubt like in doubt is the
emotion that keeps us connected to
believing in the past
and then feeling the elevated emotion
kept causes us to believe more in the
future and it only takes that image of
the future and the emotion the thought
and the feeling the stimulus and
response where you start conditioning
the body into the mind or the emotion of
that future and and he's he's in a new
body he's in a new life he's in a whole
new future wow just an instant yeah wow
this brings up something that I was
curious about which is the difference
between
believing and knowing yeah yeah and
that there's still possibly a Resonance
of not believing if you need to say I
believe and that what I'm maybe hearing
is that there's some transition that
happens as they go through this process
where they just know
so is there a difference between those
two
some people do the work and when they
finish their meditation they believe
less
in their future because they actually
never overcame themselves they never
overcame that emotion right and there's
a story that's connected to that emotion
because emotions are residue chemically
of the past there's others who get up
who believe more in their future uh when
they finish the meditation and that's
the way it should be because they change
their state they change their state of
being
so so this is a great conversation
because I've been really exploring this
in my own in my own Journey
um belief is like pregnancy like either
you are or you're not I mean there's no
in between
uh when people have a profound
experience in their meditation
where something switches where they have
some inward moment that somehow
everything aligns the brain their body
everything lines up that kind of that
kind of alignment is an absolute
knowingness there is a knowingness that
takes place and I listened to so many of
them in the last few months say I know
I'm going to heal we just were Niagara
Falls we did a big event there and some
physician 41 years in medicine uh with a
big spinal cord tumor he had that he had
the tumor removed and they put a stint
in there and he was paralyzed for the
last 10 years and he's walking around
what he talked about more than anything
else
I he was I I was right there with him in
the audience he could he could not stop
talking about the amount of love
that he was feeling he said he had he
had never felt
that amount of love in his life now I
had to force him into saying and and
what else so how did that affect your
body oh yeah I came in a wheelchair now
I can walk around a lot better and I
have no doubt I know now I know
I'm going to heal I know it this is and
that's like that is the that is what
SEALs the belief into a complete uh
finality and so he's not trying to
believe
he he knows he knows that he knows and
there's no effort yeah exactly so so
many times people during their
meditation
have an inward event
that has such a profound uh experience
for them that they realize that inward
event produces a feeling of Love or some
connection that's trans Transcendent of
language where they where they
it the amount of Love or the amount of
Joy or the amount of bliss or ecstasy
that they feel from that moment is a
really important moment of Reckoning
because they realize it's not coming
from anybody out there it's not coming
from the relationship it's not coming
from the Wardrobe it's not coming from
their diet it's not coming from their
sports car it's not coming from Netflix
it's not coming from social media this
is a really profound feeling that they
never ever felt before that moment of
connection
somehow causes a biological upgrade in
the body and in that moment there's a
alignment to a future where they already
know and it's not like they're trying to
know
it's the side effect of some inward
event and and now they live their life
in a state of knowing and that's so much
better than doubt you know or disbelief
I went to your retreat at the end of
2020 and there's a lot of talk about 3D
versus 5D creation
and
what this sounds like to me or what
maybe I'm asking is when you get to that
point
of having that knowing or feeling
something so deeply and having that
coherence
resonance in the body are you connecting
now to the simultaneous timelines in the
quantum field of that reality actually
happening that you could feel it like
so I'm asking that and I'm asking I get
and I'm saying I would get overwhelmed
with the idea of parallel timelines and
being able to have time collapse into
everything happening simultaneously so I
just want to say that I'm it confuses my
head I can't see it clearly it doesn't
make sense to me but I trust in it so is
that kind of what's happening and I
really want to talk about creating in 5D
because I think that's where we're at
okay so I'm gonna have to unpack that a
little bit I I think this is a great
conversation okay um and for the for the
audience I think we just got to lay down
a little foundation so we don't lose
anybody right perfect so we live in a 3D
three-dimensional reality everything
that we look at an object a person
anything that's physical or material has
height and depth and width and we can
pick things up right and we can say well
that's an object and I have I have a
body and now that I have a body and I'm
aware I'm a Consciousness then I'm local
in space and time and and in this
reality of three-dimensional reality
there's an infinite amount of space
space is eternal space is actually
accelerating right now it's no longer
expanding it's accelerating okay so we
know that space is eternal and the way
we experience time in three-dimensional
reality is we have to go from one point
of awareness like I'm stand sitting here
and if I want to go to my garden I put
my attention on another point of
awareness that's my other point of
Consciousness now if I want to have the
experience of getting to my garden or
picking a piece of
uh fruit off my tree I have to move my
body through space and when I move from
one point of awareness to the other
point of awareness that that interval is
called time so everything in
three-dimensional reality takes time to
create you you you experience separation
I'm here and you're there and
everything's separate from me and so
our senses plug us into
three-dimensional reality think about
this if you weren't if you were lost all
your senses you weren't seeing you
weren't hearing you weren't smelling you
weren't tasting you couldn't feel with
your body you would have no experience
of three-dimensional reality and yet you
would be conscious and aware but you
would have no interaction with anything
physical or material okay that makes
sense
all right so then the way we get about
creating our future is that we say Okay
I want to have this new house I want to
have a dog I want to have a new
relationship I want to live in this
place and what the brain automatically
does based on its experience of itself
up until that point remember the brain
is a record of the past it's it's a
Memory Bank of everything you've learned
and experienced so the brain says okay
let me predict how this is going to
happen I got to take on a second job
okay I got to start saving my beans uh I
got to make better choices
um uh I may actually uh try to figure
out a way to invest better you know
you're gonna and and your brain says
okay I'm gonna have that life in two
years if I do if I if I if I get my
behaviors to match my intentions and I
keep making the same choices I'm going
to run into that experience okay so
let's think about it the same thing
occurs there's me here Joe dispenza I'm
aware that I'm local in space and time
and then where's my future way out there
my brain is forecasting it way out in
the future based on what I've done in
the past or what I know about myself in
the past okay so now I gotta go from
this point to that point and I'm
separate
from that experience so I'm gonna spend
my entire life waiting for that
experience to happen
to take away the lack or separation from
from having it so the interval between
the thought of what I want and the
experience of having it is called time
cause and effect right so then as we
said earlier when you have the
experience you get the house you know
and you pay it off and it takes 30 years
you know you're you're too old to enjoy
it you're going to sell it anyway you
know you you're everything's you know
you've it's everything's taken a lot of
time yeah and a lot of energy and it
takes a lot of time and energy to move
your body through space and time and
then throw in the hormones of stress and
stress is when you can't predict
something when you have the perception
something's going to get worse or you're
going to lose control of something in
your life you switch on that pretty
primitive system where you're going to
mobilize all your energy and it turns
out that those very chemicals actually
heighten the senses and we become more
of a materialist and we narrow our focus
on everything physical and material why
because the alert system through
adrenaline or epinephrine norepinephrine
is saying pay attention to the danger
sure so if there's something rustling in
the bushes and it's nighttime you're
going to freeze you're going to narrow
your focus
and you're going to look for something
physical or material right okay so let's
look at the human being over
Generations Untold I mean just 300 years
ago 200 years ago being a human being
wasn't easy I mean a starvation a
disease
um Predator I mean all kinds of things
were or is a strong reality so we spent
a lot of time living in survival and
living in survival over Generations
causes us to only see the material world
because that's relevant you're not gonna
really wasn't that long ago yeah and
there's a lot of things yeah and so why
would you look for energy or frequency
or the quantum or the immaterial when
everything material is vital when you're
living in survival so keep that survival
system switched on for an extended
period of time
the arousal of those hormones causes you
to feel more like your body you have
more attention on your body because if
T-Rex is chasing you you better be
thinking about your body okay and when
you're under stress and you're in
survival your attention is on the
environment why because that's where the
danger is so so now what's your
environment made of objects things
places bodies people right so it's very
material okay so now right the arousal
causes us to pay more attention to the
outer world and less attention to our
inner world than those Rush of chemicals
causes us to become very preoccupied
with trying to make that feeling of
survival and stress go away so time
becomes very relevant as well so now
your body is where you put your
attention your environment is where you
put your attention and your attention is
on time well it turns out to change is
actually to be greater than your body to
be greater than your environment and be
greater than time so if people are
spending the majority of their life with
the emergency system switched on
it's not a time to create it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to go
within it's not a time to meditate it
goes against the survival Gene that says
you will be prey it's not a time to open
your heart it's not a time to commune
it's not even a time to eat look at the
last few years yeah so people spend the
majority of their time
shutting uh let me say it another way so
then so then when a person is living in
survival and they're trying to control
and predict
and change everything that's going on in
their life every person that they know
every object or thing that they own
every place that they know or have lived
or go to and everything they've
experienced in their past they're going
to try to predict in their future so now
the arousal the stress hormones causes
the brain to fire out of order because
every person every object everything has
a different neurological Network in the
brain now the brain is firing in
coherently and when it's firing
incoherently we're incoherent at the
same time
you're sitting in the zoom meeting and
it's not T-Rex it's your co-worker and
you're actually producing the same
chemicals as if you're being chased by
T-Rex but you don't you're not running
you're not fighting
you're not hiding you're doing sitting
there and those those chemicals are
running through the body and the heart
is actually pumping really hard because
it's turned on and it's got a run fight
or hide and you're sitting there
and the heart is actually pumping
against the closed system and the Heart
starts to become incoherent and when
incoherence takes place in the heart the
interference of of waves actually causes
energy to drop in the heart so now you
have no energy in the heart you have no
energy in the brain and now the person
is living in their animal self in that
animal nature right and so they're
waiting
for something to change in their outer
world
they're waiting for something to change
in their outer world to take away this
feeling of fear or anxiety or
frustration or impatience or resentment
or pain or suffering or guilt or shame
and they're living by that emotional
state and they would rather cling
to those memories and those emotions
because at least it's the known right
in its survival
why because in survival the unknown you
better run from the unknown there's
better chances of survival so nobody
takes a chance right okay so so then
back to the 3D World then
the Newtonian world the classical world
of quantum physics is all about a
Newtonian physics is all about the
predictable right and we can shoot a
rocket to the moon if we know the
distance and the speed of the rocket we
can determine the time it's going to
take to get there so this
three-dimensional reality is all about
predictions right okay well you can get
what you want but you got to work really
hard and it's going to take a lot of
time and energy you can develop the
skills to get it okay now so is there
possibly another way to do it I mean
okay let's look at another way is there
another way to actually
do it in a shorter amount of time to
shorten the distance between the thought
of what you want and the experience of
having it between the cause and the
effect from one point of Consciousness
uh I'm here and another point of
Consciousness I want the experience of
this here is there a way to do that okay
well let's unpack the whole model of
quantum physics
okay so you look at it Adam an atom is
99 99
nothing and I say nothing I mean it's
energy it's nothing it's a point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero one
percent physical and material and it is
a signator yeah that's what we're made
of and it's a scientific fact
it's the the mathematics prove that
we're perceiving less than one percent
of reality okay so what we're perceiving
then is the frequency of light the
wavelength of light coming off the sun
which is the the rainbow bouncing off of
objects that give us the illusion of
Separation in three-dimensional reality
okay that's that's what we're seeing
right we're seeing and experiencing the
material world by light being being
projected onto it
take away the light out of
three-dimensional reality
um you don't really have a whole lot of
experience of it you bump into a lot of
things I mean take away all light okay
so so the the atom is both particle
material and wave and what's wave what
is wave frequency what is frequency
energy what is frequency and energy do
they carry information okay so the
quantum field then is that invisible
field of energy a frequency that exists
beyond our senses that we're not
perceiving but it still exists just
because we're unaware of it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist okay so
how much of your waking day in your
Waking Life do you put your attention on
matter
and how much of your waking date you put
your attention on frequency and energy
well throw in the hormones of stress
and your attention's on your body on the
environment in time where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so now all of your energy and attention
is is invested in this three-dimensional
reality and it appears really real
because that's where our attention is
okay
so in that state we said okay if the
quantum field exists we know it does
we're just unaware of it we can
experience it with our senses the only
thing that we can experience it with is
our awareness okay so let's think about
the quantum field
let's take away everything physical and
material in the entire universe let's
take away all the bodies all the people
all the things all the objects all the
places take away the Earth take away the
Moon take away all the planets take well
the moons from the planets take away the
light from the planets take away the sun
take away the light from the sun take
away the Stars take the galaxy take away
all the light from all the stars what
are you left with a vacuum a void
nothing physical right it's just it's
it's nice It's Just Energy exactly it's
all well this is experience that at some
point yeah so the same energy that's
made up is making up the atom is the
same is the same exact void or vacuum
that the entire universe sits in so so
Okay so we've discovered that if we ask
people to go from a narrow Focus
um where they're focusing on something
physical and material ask them to expand
their focus or broaden their focus and
take their attention off of everything
known everything physical and material
and keep investing their attention and
energy
on nothing
somehow the brain gets very orderly and
very coherent different compartments of
the brain that were once divided start
to unify now that void that vacuum that
immaterial that nothing The Ether the
formless the structuralist whatever you
want to call that is pregnant
in possibilities now
in that Realm of the quantum you have to
cross through a door and what we
discovered is if you take your attention
off your body
you take your attention off of everybody
in your life you take your attention off
your cell phone and everything that you
everything that's physical and material
you take your attention off where you're
sitting where you sleep where you live
where you work where you need to be and
you take your attention off the familiar
past or the predictable future and you
find The Sweet Spot of the present
moment and you go to those place of
being nobody no one no thing nowhere in
no time you're disinvesting all of your
attention and energy out of this
three-dimensional reality
and the moment you do that you cross
through the fourth dimension which is
time and that's the moment you become
pure Consciousness that's the moment we
call getting Beyond yourself now people
are so conditioned that they're a name
they're a face they're a body they're a
diet they're a disease they're a
profession their personality their
identity we have to lay all of that down
you can't walk through the door to the
quantum field as a somebody you got to
walk through as a nobody so that process
of getting Beyond yourself it takes it
takes a couple days in our Retreats for
people to actually disentangle from
their programs and their conditioning
and and their unconscious thoughts which
makes up 95 percent of Who We Are by the
time we're in the middle of our life to
to to to be greater than our unconscious
habits and behaviors and really work
with the body that wants to feel an
emotion from something and you're
sitting there and it's getting agitated
and impatient and frustrated and all
you're doing is sitting there should
tell us volumes about ourselves so that
process of overcoming the self is
actually the process of becoming
somebody else so
the person can lingers pure
Consciousness and emptiness in a vacuum
and avoid and be comfortable there
they're they're existing in the unknown
that's where all those possibilities
exist and we enter a realm called time
space now that's The Fifth Dimension now
this is heady but just hang in there
with me
in the quantum there's an infinite
amount of time time is eternal now if
time is eternal if it's there's an
eternal now imagine how many things
you could get done if you had an
infinite amount of time
and if a number of possibilities that's
the quantum now in the quantum there's
nothing structural there's nothing
material there's nothing physical
there's no form right so what is it made
of it's made of energy frequency
vibration
thought Consciousness information and
every thought in that realm has a
frequency so all possibilities already
exist you don't have to create the
possibility in fact all you have to do
is become aware that exists
the moment you do that you you're
changing the thought and you're
producing a different frequency now if
the person is astute enough to feel the
frequency of the thought in the quantum
and not wait for the experience to
happen but the thought of abundance
would produce the feeling of abundance
for most people in three-dimensional
reality the thought of abundance
produces the lack of not having it
that's why they're trying to create it
right but in the quantum you got to feel
it in order to experience it okay so as
you get closer and closer to that point
that source that Singularity pure love
the zero point field whatever you want
to call it a universal mind that the
Creator pure Consciousness as you get
closer and closer to it
the closer you get to it the more bliss
the more love the more the more
um
ecstasy you feel uh then you're not no
longer creating from lack or Separation
The Closer you get to it in the process
of creation the shorter the distance
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of having it between the
cause and the effect from one point of
Consciousness then the other point of
Consciousness so then people can create
from the field instead of from matter
if they have a coherent brain and a
coherent heart and they actually can
send the coherent signal out and feel
the emotion ahead of the experience then
those synchronicities and opportunities
that they're creating from fifth
dimensional reality requires doing less
somehow it's drawn to us or it comes to
us it comes in ways that we least expect
that surprises us like whoa where did
that come from and now what does that do
it proves to you that you're the creator
of your life that instead of the victim
of your life and what's a victim you say
to someone why are you feeling this way
what's wrong with you today and they say
I am this way
because of that person because of that
circumstance what they're really saying
is that person or circumstances actually
controlling my feelings and controlling
my thoughts well anything that's
controlling my feelings and my thoughts
I'm victim to right so it makes sense
then that when things are good you feel
good when things are bad you feel bad
right so so when you start changing the
way you think and feeling it starts
producing outcomes in your life you're
going to believe you're more you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life and the hardest part
about all of this is just making the
time to do it ah well he just landed on
I have two things I want to ask in mind
but the first was why is it so damn hard
like why is it so hard to get to that
place where you can
whether it be believe that leads to
knowing like why what is what are those
big hurdles for people to get over and
you know one is making the time to do it
but then there's like being in it and
actually in it being hard like I
struggle with that sometimes you where
you really am to embody the the feeling
and to really like get yourself there
it's it feels like there's so many
blockages it's a difficult thing to
achieve yeah well I think it's it's so
much easier to forget this information
than to remember it I think it's I think
we're wired I'm so wired uh to for such
limitation you know and and as I said my
belief about human potential has changed
so dramatically so the first thing I
think is so valuable
is this information in the right
information sure you know we do really
best our best to combine quantum physics
with Neuroscience with neural
Endocrinology with psychoneuroimmunology
Mind Body Connection epigenetics protein
metabolism cellular biology
electromagnetism why because if
knowledge is power knowledge about
yourself is self-empowerment so
every time you learn something new
you're forging Connections in your brain
but the research shows if you don't
repeat it you don't review it you don't
think about it they prune apart within
hours or even days so if learning is
making those connections and remembering
is maintaining and sustaining them okay
so if you can build a model of
understanding with people and nothing
has left the conjecture nothing is left
to Superstition nothing's left the dogma
and they can learn that information and
instead of getting on their cell phone
and scrolling through their social media
or looking at whatever watching TV or
getting distracted if they learn that
information and they have the
opportunity to teach it back to somebody
and they begin to share that information
in right in the event right so there's
Retreats and the Retreats when you when
you give information to people you're
like okay now talk to talk about it to
each other and we stop and we talked
about it and and it's it become if you
don't understand the information well
and if you can't explain it yeah it's
not wired in your brain but if you can't
explain it you're installing the
neurological Hardware in your brain for
what in preparation for the experience
so we've discovered the more you
understand what you're doing yeah and
why you're doing it
the better results the how gets easier
and you assign meaning to the task and
when you assign meaning to a task
prefrontal cortex turns on and says that
the brain shut up quiet down here this
is a moment where I want to really
execute really well and it silences all
the other circuits in the brain so you
can focus on a single-minded thought so
if there's doubt if there's conjecture
if there's Superstition then there's
hope and there's trying and there's
wishing and there's wanting but if you
really can understand the what and the
why
then how becomes so much more
instrumental so because you've installed
the circuitry in your brain to do
something with it okay so
if we give people numerous opportunities
to experience the truth of that
philosophy that theory that knowledge
that information that's still it's still
void of experience get enough people
together and teach them instruct them
how to do it give them numerous
opportunities to overcome themselves
numerous opportunities to connect sooner
or later they're going to start figuring
it out and that's what happens at our
events now so when they have the
experience of doing it well and they
feel the emotion like wow that felt
really good the emotion is now teaching
the body chemically right to understand
what the Mind understood so it's not
just in the mind now it's in the body
you're embodying the truth of that
philosophy now you get that feeling of
getting it right and you feel unlimited
you feel grateful you feel empowered you
feel whatever that is and you're not
getting it can get visceral like really
it should be visceral or you cry or you
should be get excited you feel it you
can feel it in your heart you can feel
it in your whole body it should be
visceral right and so that so then you
so now now when you have that feeling
you go I gotta remember this feeling
this is this is what I'm doing it for
right okay so so then if you've done it
once then
you got to be able to do it again and
that's that that's the that's the key
and if you can keep repeating the
experience you start mastering the
knowledge and you neurochemically
condition your mind and body to begin to
work as one and when you've done it
enough times well you know this you're
you're you're you're you're excelled in
in automotive racing so it gets
automatic it gets easy gets second
nature the things that you had to put so
much conscious attention on in the
beginning you actually don't have to pay
a lot of attention to because you've
kind of mastered this hardwired now it's
automatic programmable right exactly
which leads me to what I'm curious I'm
like I want to have a little bit of a
almost a philosophical or maybe
perspective conversation on what are we
and tell a story that I experienced I
went ahead and gave myself a hero's dose
of psilocybin and experienced myself as
waveform all the reality is is inter
like intersecting with these waveforms
sometimes they cross sometimes they go
over each other over and over again
whatever all that's what it was and that
to get back to being human I had to
agree to the mind which essentially was
the ego the stories it's the lie I knew
it wasn't real to be human but that I
had to agree to the mind to build that
construct and so that kind of fits in
with the things you're saying is is
being in this wave form and so it makes
me wonder what are we and then when I
think about you explaining us as humans
whether it's breaking the habit of being
yourself and reprogramming yourself like
your book or you know the things you
just said it's like we're a lot like a
computer what the hell are we
well well look I mean that's a that's a
pretty heavy question but yeah
I will tell you that at our very nature
we are Divine at our very nature we are
the blooming of material which and
material reality right is is the most
stable form of energy that's really what
it is you start climbing up closer to
source and it gets way more fluid way
more Dynamic but but matter is the
slowest frequency that we perceive with
our senses and so so that so that that
one percent of reality that we perceive
don't exclude yourself
uh in that equation you're part of that
there's a 99 of the unknown self that
has fallen Source from Singularity from
Oneness from wholeness from pure love
all the way down into density fooled by
our Senses Into the illusion of
Separation why did we come from Source
because
well we're one and and then what if we
were many and what if there's is there
anything else but Oneness and that
question starts the whole journey of
every single person having a piece of
source in them to answer the question to
explore is there is there what what what
is how big is eternity well how much can
we experience and now the journey is
down in the density uh and then you
experience everything and then all of a
sudden he gets to a point
where nothing is making that feeling of
emptiness go away and you ask the same
question this is when the soul wakes up
and you start wondering is there
anything else besides this is this it
and that's a moment we start remembering
that we are Divine and so at our very at
our very core
we're we're pure love that's what we are
and so so then the the journey is to
discover the unknown self the the
journey is can I heal myself uh can I if
I heal myself can I heal somebody else
which is we have data to show that you
can if I heal myself and I heal someone
else can I heal someone else at a
distance we have data to show that you
can do that these are all new
experiences and the feelings that come
from the experience of people who are
actually healing another person
is a feeling that's Transcendent of any
anything in the three-dimensional world
the the watching a mother whose child
was born with a birth defect that never
engaged with her brothers or couldn't
hold their head up and was listless
after one remote healing is now smiling
and looking at her brothers I mean in
the mother who tells that story
um you know we're all on the call there
and we're sobbing in so much there's an
empathy that takes place where you're
you're contributing
into someone's life in some way and
you're sharing the feeling that that
person is feeling and the greatest form
of gratitude is when we receive
gratitude so you're part of someone
else's transformation and pro-social
networks switch on and the species of
human beings does something so important
we move closer together we commune We
Trust we support we inform we love we
heal right we shine and and then our
appreciation for everything in the
moment we see more Beauty in the moment
stress hormones divide us separate us
cause us to be selfish this is the the
so who we are is success of who we
really are exactly exactly we move
further away from love right so of
course speaking from my present state of
ignorance what I've discovered is that
when people have that moment of
connection
we see this on the brain scan
their skin goes into such an aroused
that scientists that look at it actually
think the person's having something
really wrong go on with them you know
because they think seizure they think
what is this but the arousal is not
coming from Fear
the arousal is not coming from pain
and the arousal is not coming from anger
or aggression that's what typically
switches on the arousal system this
arousal is ecstasy this arousal is bliss
this is the person actually dipping into
the Divine and touching it and they feel
it in every single atom in their body
all resonating in order the side effect
of that
is some transcendental experience that
produces a shift in the perception of
the way they perceive reality the
spectrum of reality is broadened and the
feeling is not chemical the feeling is
kind of electric it's kind of
frequency it's energy in that person
many times has a biological upgrade
there's the tumor on their throat now
it's gone there's the Parkinson's
disease now it's gone
there's the eczema now it's gone there's
the paralysis from the surgery now the
person's walking there's an their
interaction with energy and frequency is
causing a part of the brain called the
autonomic nervous system the limbic
brain is is resonating in such high
frequency remember stress is autonomic
dysregulation this is autonomic high
amount of autonomic regulation and every
cell in the body is getting informed
with more wholeness more Oneness more
love and the cells emit more coherent
light in information and the person all
of a sudden realizes never was outside
of them so the Journey Back To Source
the journey back to Oneness the Journey
Back everybody gets to you can be
anybody you want to be in three
dimension it can be any character you
want to be in the virtual reality
experiences the simulation that we're
experiencing
but if you're living by the same
emotions every day
or you can't get out of bed because you
can predict the feeling of everything
that's going to happen in your life then
nothing's going to change until you
change and the discovery of okay
most people have to hit their lowest
point in their life where that nothing's
making that feeling go away to finally
look at how they think look at how they
act look at how they feel my message is
why wait for that like and so what we're
discovering is in seven days in seven
days the science that we have
is so compelling to show that in seven
days there will be a host of biological
changes that take place in a person's
body to actually look like they're
living in a new environment living in a
whole new life
so then
getting over yourself to answer your
question is the difficulty that's why
people will say uh it's too hard for me
but what they're really saying is I
don't believe in that I don't really
don't believe in it because if you
believe in it
you got to show up and if you don't
believe in it then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself that means you don't believe in
possibility if you don't believe in
possibility that means you can't believe
in yourself right so yeah so this this
idea of potential possibilities it's
connected to everything what you're
saying is is that when people have this
upgrade they connect with more of
themselves with essential essentially if
we're not we're not separate from
anything then you connect with more of
yourself and you get bigger your energy
gets bigger you get upgraded makes me
wonder like what is consciousness then
because that was another failing I had
was that I was aware of being waveform
I'm also aware of Being Human so there's
this overlay of Consciousness over the
top of the whole experience ah very good
very good because source is pure
Consciousness it's the consciousness of
everybody of everyone of everything of
everywhere and everything connected yeah
of course we're fishing water asking for
a drink or sponge sitting in the ocean
wondering where's the ocean it's it's
within us and it's all around us and we
just haven't made the time to be patient
enough
to actually put our attention on it and
once we've become aware of it it is
conscious that it's conscious of us it's
it's a collect it's a consciousness of
everybody very you're not separate from
it so then there's there's subjective
Consciousness you and I you know there
there is one source but in that Source
there are many but there's one Divine in
that Divine there are many there's one
God in that God there are many okay
everybody's got a spark of the Divine in
them okay so that's subjective
Consciousness and then there's the
objective consciousness
how come the planets are rotating in
such order how come there's forces of
nature that have
so much order after the Big Bang there
should have been disorder that's what
happens after an explosion how come
there's so much order after an explosion
well there's only one reason for that
and that's because there's a
Consciousness that's that's aware of the
whole entire thing because they're very
fabric of everything material is energy
and I mean breaking 99 everything
material is actually energy it's just
stable Consciousness and it's the
slowest form frequency the slowest
energy that's stable that we can
perceive with our senses climb up the
scale closer to source and it gets very
very Dynamic and very different so so
the discovery then
of Consciousness and its never-ending
process of self-discovery and answering
the question is there more because most
people wake up in the morning and the
first thing they do is since the brain
is a record of the past they think about
their problems
those are memories that are wretched in
the brain that are connected to certain
people and objects certain things at
certain times and places the moment you
start remembering your problems you're
thinking in the past that's what a
memory is every one of those problems
has an emotion associated with it the
moment you feel unhappy the moment you
feel discouraged the moment you feel
frustrated now you're in the past
thoughts of the language of the brain
feelings of language of the body so most
people
unconsciously take that thought and that
feeling that memory that emotion that
stimulus and response now the body is
the mind so when it comes time to change
and you got to step from that known
familiar feeling and make a different
choice and step into the unknown the
body says Ah listen
um you think you've been running the
show here for the last 20 years but
actually I've been running the show I've
actually been telling you the choices to
make so you can feel that familiar
feeling to reaffirm you it's an
incredible computer we're just a
simulation so the body begets
conditioned there and now to overcome
the body
takes a will that's greater than the
program to to no longer get up and run
through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants to in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say way way way
wait a second here we're not going
anywhere until I get clear on who I want
to be today and every time you execute
that will that's greater than the
program people say oh I can't meditate
actually you're doing it right actually
that's why it's hard because you're
actually that is the process right there
there's no such thing as a bad
meditation what you're doing is actually
exactly what you need to do and every
time you do that you become conscious
that you go unconscious that's how you
actually develop the skill of
Consciousness it's not being conscious
it's catching yourself when you go
unconscious and people if they can see
the thing is the unconscious essentially
conscious is connecting to everything
which is in the space of nothingness
really but there's a journey to get
there yeah and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that
as a victory
like oh you start getting aroused you
start getting frustrated and you think I
can't do this and you go oh no no no no
no no no no we're not going to quit here
that would be me getting up as the same
person I'm curious what's on the other
side of this frustration you settle your
body back down into the present moment
you unfold back into that Eternal space
I'm telling you every time you do that
it's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and it actually turns out that the
body starts liberating energy it starts
real liberating energy but like an
unbridled stallion it goes oh really
you think that's all you think that's
all you have watch this and then it gets
starts bringing up memories of the past
and all of that just to feel an emotion
and if you're aware that it's doing that
and you settle it down you're taming the
animal you're teaching it you're you're
teaching it how to change its state
right and guaranteed if you keep doing
that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in seven days we see that not only
their dramatic biological changes to
suggest that the person for an
environment
but it it goes for the majority of
people
that immerse themselves in going all in
and what does that mean a different
environment they're in a ballroom
they're in a ballroom I've been to
thousands of ballrooms there's nothing
really exciting in a ballroom what's
exciting in the ballroom they all look
the same but the data suggests that
they're in a whole new environment where
where is that where is that taking place
it's taking place from within the person
those died internal world is of course
everything
open your eyes you get locked into
static things that just exist but when
you close your eyes this is kind of one
of the things that
different states of being whether it's
induced by meditation or plant medicines
or those things they show you that
there's a whole big universe inside when
you close your eyes but when you open
them it slows things out it's almost
like I had the feeling like being human
is actually a pause because there's so
much information available that this
goes okay so there's a picture there's
the window there's a okay and then my
dog and right
um and it just feels like you know you
get to slow down for a second but in
that closed-eyed world there's a lot
there yeah it's really slow here it's
really slow here and and everything
material is actually a symbol
and every we're perceiving it as a
symbol because we couldn't handle oh
yeah all the information be able to
function all at once that's the
challenge that's exactly what happened
in that wave form I was asking questions
and getting answers and I am a I like I
have a lot of questions I do too this is
why I interview people I do too yeah
so I was getting all the answers every
time I asked and it was like rapid fire
and I popped up after like two hours and
I'm like I just can't hold the frequency
it's too much information and that's
when I said Being Human is a pause from
all the information I can't hold that
frequency and that's what made me
realize that's why we have to grow and
um like raise our Consciousness level
slowly because it's too much information
otherwise it's too overloading you would
short circuit you just shut down you I
can't do this anymore but there's so
well because there's everything which is
essentially back to the 5D is that you
know and I go like that because of how
you described it like 3DS you know A to
B 5D is is
all possibilities everything in that
space
every answer I wanted yeah it's a lot
and and I think you're absolutely
correct about that I mean to fall from
Singularity down in the density you had
to forget that you were Oneness you have
to forget it also reminded me of that I
was like that's why we forget too
because otherwise you couldn't you
couldn't participate in this reality if
you knew this wasn't real right and you
we really think that this is real we
really do and it's actually and actually
this reality couldn't exist without the
other one right so so have you ever had
an experience like that have you am I
speaking of you can you so so I mean my
my whole thing what I love uh on my own
journey is really is really the mystical
I mean mystical being the unknown of
course yeah and and that process of
self-discovery when you truly hit that
fertile void that beautiful place where
of Singularity where your Consciousness
is actually merged with the greater
Consciousness there's no separation
right
um the thought of what you're thinking
about actually gives you the exact
experience or the information because
it's all information there
um
a a whole portal of possibilities open
My Hope Is that when I come back to
three-dimensional reality that I take a
piece of that with me because every
mystical experience that I've ever had
I've always come back and said Joe
dispenza
who got this all wrong dude it's you got
it all wrong you're it's not the way it
is it's not that way and so some Veil
yeah some conditioning some illusion is
removed and all of a sudden I see things
how they really are and and it's not the
way I have been conditioned or
programmed and so that process is should
be
integrated into our nervous system
because if it happens too randomly or
too quickly we can't function in our
three-dimensional world and we've got to
be able to function right we've got to
keep one foot in the real world and one
foot in the quantum World otherwise you
know you wind up with a psychosis and
you can't function right so so it's
healthy for for us to interact at the
level of our ability to be able to
process it and every now and then you
have a big one and it's more than you
can take I've had those two but but for
me I want to hear about that that's what
I want to hear about I want to hear
about it in a story and experience well
well
um I never really want to make it be
about me but there are plenty of people
that have really profound moments uh you
know I'm looking you know I'm I'm very
empirical when it comes to stuff like
this and you know when you see someone's
brain scan go off the chart I mean off
the chart
and they could be vegan they could be
gluten free they could eat meat doesn't
matter like we've we asked all the
questions but when you see the person's
brain like light up like that not a
little bit I mean the mathematical
probability
of some of these brainwave States
according to the research is they say
statistically impossible to occur and if
it does occur it would be a random event
that would last for a millisecond and
you see this sustained state in the
brain and it's hundreds and hundreds of
standard deviations outside of normal
three standard deviations outside of
normal is two percent of the population
that's really good now you're talking
hundreds past that point
person is having a very transcendental
moment
the stories that they tell like oh my
God I just the Divine was it was always
there I just was unaware of it or I met
my future self and My Future Self does
not have colon cancer I'm telling you I
know it I know it and when you look at a
brain scan like that you think this
person's having some inner event that
they can't make their brain do that you
know it's kind of happening to them so
somehow and this has happened to me Vera
The Observer they're they're
experiencing whatever it's experiencing
they're outside of time experiencing
looking at themselves having it and
they're in their future at the same time
at those at that person realizing I'm
Healed from this colon cancer and all of
it's happening
simultaneously you cannot go back to
business as usual and live your life in
the same mediocre way it's just
impossible you know too much so the
seduction or the interest then becomes
not about experiencing anything in this
3D World now do I think I love my 3D
World I love to eat I loved it I chose
to came back come back I was like I want
to come back at one point there was a
choice to not come back and I was like
no no I want to be human yeah and all of
a sudden I love it I love the Journey of
all that I just think that there's more
to reality than we perceive and I think
it's an instinct in our mind it's an
intuition in our heart that never seems
to go away and I think it's that feeling
brings people to to to Really that
process of discovery they may not be
able to explain it or put it into words
but they feel it and they felt that
their entire lives and what that feeling
is is that this isn't this cannot be the
end this that just can't be so and so
what do I find so promising is that
uh I said to my scientific team the
other day I said I can't believe this is
the truth I really cannot believe this
is the truth I mean what was once
considered pseudoscience we now have
data my one of our top scientists did a
presentation a couple weeks ago and his
last line this is a very well published
guy 175 papers his last line is you are
what you think that was his last line I
looked at him and I thought what was
this Buddha on the stage like I cannot
believe so when you say I can't believe
this is true what's the thing that you
can't believe the body and the nervous
system
is manufacturing and an endogenous group
of pharmaceuticals in the body innately
in the body that works way better than
any drug like well it's always mimicking
us right isn't that the the sort of the
thing is that drugs usually mimic
something in nature or something within
us right but what the data says is like
okay you do a drug study it's about 18
to 25 causality cause and effect that's
not bad our data is 75 cause and effect
it works three times better four times
better than any drug and yet it's within
us and I keep saying to the scientists
where are all those chemicals coming
from the person's not taking anything
they're sitting there with their eyes
closed it's the frequency when there's a
coherent brain and a coherent heart that
the nervous system can actually tune and
read that frequency and what are the
what is it reading it's reading
information so energy is informing
matter and the what we're capturing in
the blood in the cell in the gene in the
brain is somehow
information that is a result of their
interaction with frequency and energy
and so it's that point of us saying it's
in the field it's it's in it's well I
couldn't say it's outside of it I'd say
it's within us and all around us yeah
yeah somehow there's a connection or an
awareness that happens and so what do I
think is occurring that's so beautiful
right now and and I'm a pretty
optimistic person the last two years you
know I keep asking myself when is all of
this going to end is there an end in
sight when I look at the world and I've
been so kind of like oh God how are we
going to get through this and
I think the veil is really thinning now
like I really believe the valve Between
Worlds of sinning and I am so optimistic
after our last event in Niagara Falls
people are walking up to the stage that
came with crutches and and canes and
were just dropping them on the stage I
couldn't believe what I was seeing there
transformed profoundly I'm like wow I
have hope again
I have hope that we we don't need
anybody or anything any longer to find
happiness or love those people were
making themselves happy they were making
themselves better that no one else was
doing that they were doing it on their
own what a powerful empowering
uh opportunity for people and and it's
the four minute mile it's the four
minute mile the ladies Physicians stood
on the stage with with really severe
surgeons she couldn't do surgery anymore
because she had such severe carpal
tunnel had the surgery nothing was
helping One Moment One Moment and one
walking meditation completely gone she
told the story on the stage by the end
of the event someone else health and
wellness starts to become as infectious
as to these why because it's in the
field it's in Consciousness and you're
witnessing the evidence in
three-dimensional reality that's so
powerful really well it makes me think
about time and I think about like
talking to Greg Braden and talking about
and maybe you guys have had this
conversation
um about just time and you've surely had
this experience though and time
accelerating and speeding up and I'm
wondering if there's any thoughts around
that or like any scientific data or just
or like anecdotal even with your
experience and what you're seeing that
and how important it is to Anchor new
reality
like we've been talking about from the
field because of this acceleration of
time and now I'm not saying I know that
scientifically or factually I'm just
saying it feels like it it feels like
things are speeding up whether it's the
veil thinning creating
um waking up it just feels like that so
what have you experienced
um I'll explain for me I'll explain it
in two ways I mean one of the ways is
unfortunately technology is actually
causing us to experience more things in
a shorter amount of time okay yeah yeah
we can do so much more in a shorter
amount of time and the side effect of
that unfortunately is that attention
spans have shortened because you can
shift your attention from one thing to
the next and if you keep doing something
over and over again you develop a habit
so
so to the person who is in
three-dimensional reality because of
Technology you can get more done in a
shorter amount of time or more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time so that that so there's a
quickening in human consciousness
because
the pace has increased right the problem
with that is that you can get on Amazon
Prime and you get something delivered to
your door the next day or sometimes even
the same day there's this kind of
entitlement of convenience that takes
place where we really think that you
know everything's going to be handed to
us or we can get whatever we want
nothing's wrong with that that's really
cool that's really great but in the
creative process
um you actually have to get outside of
time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so
yes there's a function of
three-dimensional reality and Technology
where more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time certainly there's
some type of energetic thing that's
taking place in so many ways and to me
that energy is actually endorsing
whoever you want to be that's what I
believe so if you want to be a victim
get ready because it's going to get
really good for you because that energy
is more available if you want to heal
wow there's a lot of people healing now
and they're using that energy
instrumentally in a positive way so so
yes there's a quickening that's taking
place and it's creating quite a contrast
or extremes that are taking place in
reality and the more extreme it gets the
more unstable the system right so uh
governments
um
journalism uh education religion
medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's it's causing people to think
uh uh instead of them for them to think
on their own and I'm concerned about
that because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
uh I think that amazing things happen
and that's exactly what we're
discovering over and over again in just
witnessing the the science
is absolutely supporting that that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more unlimited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
Cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind I mean now
you know I'm you know I'm a healthy
skeptic I mean this woman saw her face
for the first time in in the mirror and
crazy too too good of a story to pass up
you can't make these up so
the testimony is the four minute mile
what was once considered impossible I
mean muscular dystrophy really the
Physicians that were in the audience
that were disbelievers they they were in
tears they just could not imagine that
this could actually take place it wasn't
matter to matter you know it wasn't 3D
reality trying to change 3D reality that
was not it was it was energy that was
actually informing about it I could
never do it that way it had it had
happened another way so you have this
amazing evidence in scientific research
and you have this amazing evidence in
human testimony and evidence is the
loudest voice and I'm so optimistic now
for the first time in a long time that
we actually can actually find our way
here that that that we have to come
together community
of the same Consciousness that isn't
angry they've overcome their anger it
isn't fearful they've overcome their
fear they're not suffering in pain
they've overcome that in their own
personal work and they're actually
showing the world what love looks like
they're showing the world what greatness
looks like they're demonstrating for the
world they're not talking about it
philosophically they're actually
demonstrating who they are so the person
who witnesses them says wow something is
really
different about you what's different
about you I don't know well there's
something different about you because
the person is not the the person who's
perceiving them doesn't match their
memory of them any longer there's
something different about the person and
that's exactly what this world needs
that Collective networks of observers
determine reality do you believe in 100
monkey Theory I do I'm actually I'm not
it's not that I believe it and I know it
now because I'm seeing
four people with Reynard syndrome in one
event all heal I mean I mean that is
that is a collective that's a
morphogenic it's the possibility that we
see the hundredth monkey Theory uh come
into effect on our level of
Consciousness globally within our
lifetime I think as we get close as the
time speeds up like it is it gets more
and more unpredictable to determine when
it's going to happen but I will tell you
this I'm so optimistic if we can
continue uh staying awake relaxed and
awake and continually doing the work and
keep pushing the edge of what's possible
the brain it's really funny you know the
brain actually changes
the most when you get to the point where
you think you can't go any further if
you go past that point if you just go
past that point that's when you see the
greatest brain changes and so we
actually push people past that point and
we give them some tools what to do there
and lo and behold we we see young people
old people we see it educated uneducated
we see a healthy sick I mean it doesn't
matter it's that because none of that
matters it's just it's it's just their
ability to be able to execute so it's
the reprogramming it's com it's it's
it's like unprogramming reprogramming it
can you know when you you know use a
fire what wall service to you know burn
things down it's Alchemy too right it's
some sort of
alchemical process happening where you
are like short-circuiting something and
growing something new and growing pains
are called that for a reason well let's
say let's make it really simple if we
are pure love if you're on the journey
anything that is not love and you must
die or in order for you to find true or
true love pure love a part of you must
die and I think that's the difference
between knowing the path uh and walking
the path walking the path is really what
it's about right how do you as you move
through your life and you have done such
phenomenal things and continue to do
more and more how do you get your
information to know what comes next like
where what direction to turn your head
to turn your energy where does that come
from and in what form
um well I never planned on doing any of
this really
um yeah and my theory from the very
beginning is uh when when this kind of
started become of interest to people I
just said to my staff
um here's how it's gonna work um I'll
only go where I'm invited if I'm not
invited I'll be a chef I'll do something
else and so so
um I'm constantly building my model of
what I understand and I'm like you
always have a thousand questions now I
had so much better for me to sit down
and take a few minutes instead of
turning on my phone or doing it I
actually like the process of
contemplation I like the process of
saying to myself so what do you know
at what point or at what point do you
stop believing that this is the truth
let's get right to that point
and let's let's build that understanding
so I'm constantly building my model
and then I'm tearing it down and then
I'm challenging and building it up again
and if I can't find like there's
something that doesn't fit then I gotta
find information somewhere that makes it
fit that makes sense to me but then it's
not enough for me there then I gotta
like then I gotta experience it like
someone said to me so what someone said
to me yesterday so what are you doing in
your morning meditations I'm like well
it's really funny because I'm I'm
actually developing a new understanding
a new model and I want to teach it at
the follow-up uh next month and
I'm actually practicing this this new
meditation to have the experience so
that I can teach it better so if I can
have the experience of that knowledge
and the model that I build I know the
journey and I can teach it much better
so I work really hard
it being the example of of what I teach
and I work really hard at getting
information either from uh well
references or whatever but also the
information that I love to get that
comes to me when I start connecting and
then it all kind of makes sense and so I
think of many ways as I can to teach it
but I also love to have the experience
because when I have the experience that
I can really teach it yeah on a much
deeper level yeah and and then now the
other thing is just the the scientific
data you know we were just all on a
research call yesterday
the date is so so amazing right now that
I can say so many more things with such
conviction I can say things now with
conviction I mean I I can say like I I
actually know that this is the truth
it's yeah so and having that kind of
conviction for me personally allows me
to trust more and and when I trust
myself more I trust the process more uh
and I can stay in that kind of
uncertainty in that unknown and not not
move into survival or I'm or better yet
let me say it another way when I'm
uncomfortable because I don't have an
answer and I can continuously keep it on
my mind and I don't you know I always
have it going somewhere and no matter
while I'm doing other things always I'm
always
thinking about him trying to figure it
out somehow if I trust the process and I
just go all in
um somehow I run into I run into the
experience where I run into a greater
understanding about it and and uh and
and then I'm able to then I'm able to
articulate it and getting it from here
to here sometimes especially you know as
you said when you have transcendental
moments
it's really hard to find words to be
able to explain that it's it's ineffable
it's like beyond words so so for me
personally I mean I just I love the
Divine I mean I love the unknown I love
the journey
um I'm never gonna stop asking questions
I can't
um every every new experience that I
have forces me to think of a infinite
number of possibilities from that
experience that I would have never
thought of without that experience so to
me there's not Infinity there's
Infinities like this is a never-ending
process here like oh now we're on to the
Multiverse oh my gosh the
oh so overwhelming the universe but also
so amazing so okay all right we'll wrap
it up like what you work your butt off
you do these Retreats you oh my God like
you do every meditation it's insane I
can't I can't I just can't imagine I
know that there's an aspect of
energizing yourself through connection
and but then there's also it's just us
also it's also a lot
um so
why what's your mission what's what what
do you hope to accomplish throughout I I
hope that on some level Danica that that
at the end of my life
uh I feel like that I've contributed to
the world in some way I mean I mean it's
not about anything else about being a
part of change and transformation you've
already done that
while it's never ending like I'm pushing
the envelope like this yeah I don't know
what's your size your envelope like
what's the ultimate goal if you were
yeah this is what I hope yeah I want
everybody to be empowered uh to realize
that that they actually can make
measurable changes in their life that
they're not defined by their past that
that they should they could be defined
by a vision of the future uh that that
on some level we leave a legacy of
information that shows people really
that that that that's the truth and for
me personally
um I wanted to be there on the beach
when that woman opened Horizon could see
for the first time I wanted her I wanted
to be right there with her and I want to
celebrate that moment with her I want to
be part of that I think there's some
something innate in us as human beings
as species where we're
but we inform each other and we we we we
support each other we trust each other
we love each other you know we heal each
other we shine for each other so others
can shine I think I think that there
could be a world where we actually
actually function in a much a much
healthier way and and I think this
really is the defining time so if I
could leave
something that could change a person's
life or help them in some way I feel
really good about it for me it just is a
it's a mission that I gets me up in the
morning and I love to be I love to be
involved in and I I'm nothing really
without my team and so my team is a
really great dedicated group of people
our scientific team our amazing Minds
that we're healthy Skeptics in the
beginning that now I'll do the work
because they see it as medicine they
know it's medicine they know how they've
done drug studies they know exactly what
it looks like these stories and
testimonials that people have I watch
them over and over again because it
changes my belief it changes my belief
and I love when scientists run an
experiment five times in a row I love
when they do that because I know they're
changing their belief right in them
they're expecting a different result and
they're getting the same result and
they're in there they're in science to
discover and they're making a huge
Discovery and it's never been outside of
the human being in the beginning so I
don't know where I'm going to end up in
in this process but if I stay true to
what I believe and then ask keep asking
greater questions I hope we we have a
really really big breakthrough in human
consciousness and uh that would be
really satisfying to me do you hope
someday or believe someday that we as
humans will interact and walk alongside
other extraterrestrials in the universe
Wow Wow Let's see how I can answer this
I wouldn't I don't know if I would use
the word extraterrestrial but I will
tell you that I've had enough
experiences with interdimensional beings
that God I would be really foolish to
say that they they don't exist and I
think there's a very very strong
interest uh in the human race right now
uh and of course there's always
characters that are deceiving along the
way without a doubt and we have to
discern but God I think I think um uh if
our Consciousness is in the state of
Love or more connection I think they can
lower their frequency to a certain point
in it's happened so many times in our
events I mean people have had really
profound healings and the stories that
they tell about their interaction with
some of these interdimensional beings
I'm taking a risk here
um I really don't care about their
subjective experience what I care about
is that their their condition is gone
and so then what is real I don't know
but whatever they experienced uh there
goes all their their goes their health
condition and for them they were
interacting with that 99 of reality that
we we don't perceive with our senses and
for them it was so real that they
they're their their their their body or
their life changed in such dramatic ways
and and God that's so something to look
forward to having a relationship with
somebody other than some something
physical that I think it's possible it's
a possibility in the quantum field
um I certainly think it's possible I've
had my own experiences and
um and and then then what then what I
mean it just keeps going why are we
interesting well I don't think human
beings are very interesting when they're
pregnant they're interested in us you
said oh yeah of course this is a very
critical there's a very critical time
for foreign because I think it's I think
it's a Crossroads I really think we're
gonna get it together or we're not
really and what does not mean wow I
think it's I just think it this is game
time
it's like a reboot and if it does if we
do get it together what does that look
like well I think uh I think that um
it's no longer a selfish Consciousness I
think it's a collective Consciousness I
think uh that that we resolve all the
problems in this world from the
environment all the way to the monetary
system to politics the government uh to
journalisms education religion just from
a greater level of Consciousness and
there's not less separation and and we
actually show that that that when we do
this we have random event generators in
our in our in our
events and it's just a sophisticated uh
coin toss you toss a coin a thousand
times in a second and programmed machine
now if you keep doing you're gonna get
50 heads 50 Tails but when we come
together
and we and we can actually execute you
have a 1500 people 2500 people in a room
all of a sudden that random event
generator becomes less random and more
intentional that the field actually
changes as a result of collective
networks of observers so it's not the
number of people and it's not the amount
of energy that really matters it's the
most coherent signal that makes the
biggest impact could be a smaller group
but more coherent that actually can
change can change the field and and we
have data to suggest that people at a
remote location that are somehow
connected or entangled actually their
brains and hearts go into coherence when
you do so there's a there's a good
possibility for us to really really move
the needle in a really healthy way and
as I said something happened for me at
the end of our last event in Niagara
Falls just the last week at the end of
that event I just I just I'm super
optimistic that that uh we're we're
we're making our way here wow that okay
thank you thank you for sharing and
thank you for all the work that you do
you're so humble and
um also so great and powerful and I've
been at your retreat and it's amazing to
watch and
um you really
yeah
there's another additional energy that
comes through you that really really
commands the space and helps educate
people and people really get it and
that's why you're seeing it so thank you
for that ah thank you for all the great
work that YouTube also I appreciate you
yeah thanks Joe thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button